In order to transform a company into a
sustainable organization in terms of
both commitment and performance.
Leaders have to approach their job,
the CEO's,
the top management of key people,
of business units and so on,
have to approach their job in a way
that,
uh,
that engages the organization in a
learning process.
Uh,
that is,
they see the problem of organization
performance as a problem of learning
both for the work for themselves and for
the organization.
Uh,
these leaders,
first of all,
connect authentically with people.
How do you,
how do they connect authentically with
people by being much more revealing
about themselves?
Uh,
so a CEO took over a company,
uh,
a restaurant company,
first management meeting spoke not only
about what the firm needed to do,
but about where he was coming from and
its own life experience had to do a lot
with his father and the values that his
father had.
Uh,
revealing those things about himself and
who he or she might be is a critical
part of engaging people in an authentic
way.
The second element of leadership is that
these leaders have to have the will to
an to essentially change the system,
change and transform the company around
a,
around the kind of philosophy and values
I've talked about.
Uh,
and around the business idea that's
going to drive the business model,
that's going to drive the organization
to better performance.
They have to have a clear vision of
that.
And they develop that vision on their
own.
And,
and,
and uh,
they bring it,
bring a lot of that with them.
But as far as the business aspects,
they have to figure that out when they
get into the firm.
But they have to have the will to
essentially articulated and push for it.
Now,
if I were to stop here,
you could also say,
well,
that can lead to autocratic management,
which is not what high commitment,
high performance firms are.
Uh,
because the next dimension of effective
leadership,
that high commitment,
high performance leaders have is the
willingness to inquire,
the willingness to state boldly what
they want and what they think they need
to do and what the firm ought to be
doing.
And why.
But also the willingness to inquire from
their own senior team,
from the organization as a whole,
from people at various levels in the
organization about whether the direction
makes sense,
whether what they see as what,
what people in the organization she as
they as the strengths of the
organization,
but also what they see as the barriers
to achieving sustainable performance.
And uh,
and that enables them to learn the truth
about the character of the company and
how it's functioning to the create
sustainability.
You have to learn about yourself as a
leader and not necessarily you as a
person only,
but also your ideas,
your strategic ideas about what you're
trying to do and whether in a business
policies you promote that.
Does that make sense?
And if you're not able to up,
if you're not able to,
uh,
obtain that feedback,
you are likely to not be able to get off
a path that you may have to get off of
to,
to sustain the performance,
uh,
over long periods of time.
The ability to inquire and obtain
feedback and,
and be vulnerable to obtain feedback is
a critical characteristic of,
of high commitment,
high performance leaders.
Uh,
this has been described in many ways,
in the less operational way as people
leave.
These leaders are humble.
They have humility.
They don't assume they are doing it
themselves.
They involve others.
They ask questions,
they try to work on a problem solving.
Basically.